hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called love
and monsters spoilers ahead watch out
and stay safe the movie begins with the
narration about the current situation of
the earth a boy named Joel Dawson says
that his life was normal until one day
when a huge asteroid named Agatha 616
was heading straight to Earth Humanity
United and sent several Rockets into
space to combat the asteroid they
succeeded and the asteroid was destroyed
however the explosion also destroyed all
the Rockets causing its radioactive
elements to Reign back to the Earth's
surface the chemical Fallout caused all
cold-blooded animals such as frogs and
snails to mutate into large aggressive
monsters after that to be safe from the
mutated monsters people started Living
inside the safe places like underground
bunkers and caves with all openings
closed they started calling the place as
colonies seven years later Joel now age
24 lives in one of many underground
bunkers called colonies he always feels
lonely inside the bunker and says that
his life is not normal inside there the
people have started their own lifestyle
which is completely different from what
it used to be before the other survivors
except for Joel have romantically paired
up with each other while fighting
monsters and Scavenging for supplies
inside the place they grow some
vegetables using the little light that
gets in they also tend to cow for their
necessary Dairy Supply and hunt for food
whenever they get out in the next Scene
It is revealed that during the
evacuation after the apocalypse a
teenage Joel was separated from his
girlfriend Amy but he promised to find
her Joel is assigned to work as a cook
as he is notorious for freezing in
dangerous situations and is considered a
liability as Joel is the only single guy
inside the colony he passes his time
doing target practice one day during his
practice he notices a rumbling sound
right above their bunker and alarms
everyone the team immediately decides to
exit and kill the monster but leave Joel
behind with some other people who can't
fight while the fighting team is out
others watch the movements on a monitor
and see one of the members get getting
killed by the monster seeing this Joel
decides he's had enough and sets off
with just a crossbow to help his friends
there he notices a large creature in
front of him attacking his friend but
cannot move an inch in fear the creature
is about to attack Joel but luckily one
of the members arrives in time to kill
the monster and save him we are then
taken into the flashback from seven
years ago when the asteroid was
destroyed by the help of rockets Joel is
in his car hanging out with his
girlfriend Amy he draws an awful picture
of Amy despite which she gifts him a box
of colors as they start to kiss and are
about to get intimate with each other
and emergency alarm goes off around the
city the remains of the Rockets fall
back on the earth creating great
explosions the two then drive back to
their home quickly where they see
everyone packing their bags to leave for
the safe place it's the day when the two
hug each other for the last time in the
next scene we see Joel Still drawing the
monsters he noticed in those seven years
with the same drawing tools Amy gifted
him before he also talks with Amy by the
help of the radio station he has during
their conversation the call all gets
disconnected Midway due to a weak signal
other team members are seen mourning
over the death of the team members Joel
then has a flashback of the day of the
Apocalypse where he and Amy embraced
each other the last time and comes up
with a feeling of uniting with her he
expresses his feelings to reunite with
Amy in one of the team meetings but
everyone warns him about the dangerous
journey and also his weakness in
dangerous situations they mentioned that
Amy's colony is about 85 miles away and
it will take him at least a week to get
there ignoring their suggestions and
warnings Joel decides to reunite with
his love and starts packing his
belongings reluctantly the other
survivors decide to help him out they
give him a map and a crossbow despite
their fear that he will not survive
after getting all his things ready Joel
heads out for the first time in seven
years Joel is out in the sunlight
breathing fresh air he then takes out
the map and starts studying it before
setting out on his journey however he is
unable to determine the directions and
heads randomly passing through the
suburbs he finds some monster eggs but
tries to remain income and moves forward
later Joel Hears A Sound and enters a
nearby house there he encounters a giant
toad monster who attacks him with its
tongue making him fall on the ground
suddenly a dog comes near Joel out of
nowhere after various attempts the toad
catches Joel by his leg and drags him
towards its mouth however the dog bits
the tongue of the toad and Joel is saved
Joel then follows the dog to a minivan
where he spends the night it seems to be
the dog's home Joel then sees boy
written in various places and assumes it
to be the dog's name next day Joel draws
the drawing of the dog in his notebook
and thanks him for saving his life Joel
resumes his journey but boy follows him
with his owner's blanket in his mouth
Joel keeps the blanket in his backpack
and with boy he walks towards his
destination on the way the two become
best friends and Joel tells him
everything about his life when Joel is
about to eat some poisonous berries boy
warns him against it and other dangers
on their way Joel falls into a nest of
worm monsters called sand gobblers he
tries to get out of it but fails despite
several attempt right then two survivors
Clyde Dutton and his adopted daughter
minnow arrive at the place and rescue
him with the help of a rope they kill
the remaining Monsters by tossing
explosives inside the hole after that
they introduced themselves and mentioned
that the two are heading north to the
mountains where the Colder Weather and
higher elevation means fewer monsters
Joel decides to follow them along with
boy until their path departs they teach
Joel some basic survival skills like how
to fight sense danger and find food
later while all of them are getting
along Clyde suddenly tells Joel not to
move as a monster is behind him he asked
Joel to take out his shirt but it takes
him some time because of his panic
attack Clyde then inserts Joel's shirt
inside the giant snail's shell telling
that the snail will now help them to be
away from another monster named chumbler
Nino also shows Joel that not all
monsters are hostile demonstrating how
one can always tell from their eyes
spending some days together Clyde
teaches him how to look out for the
monsters and minnow assists him for his
targeting skills the pair invite Joel to
stay with them but Joel insists that he
must find Amy his teenage love as they
part ways Clyde gifts Joel with a
grenade and suggests to use it only when
it is necessary as Joel continues West
boy seems terrified as if he has sensed
some danger boy immediately hides under
a boat and Joel runs after him Joel then
notices some tentacles emerging out from
the ground and grabs his crossbow to
attack the monster centipede attacked by
a giant centipede monster Joel freezes
and remembers his parents getting
crushed by a giant monster's feet after
having seen losing his parents Joel now
feels he cannot lose boy after Gathering
a lot of Courage he eventually shoots
the centipede and kills it with his
crossbow saving boy that night it starts
to rain and they take shelter in an
abandoned Motel there they meet a
damaged cyborg named Mavis Joel is aware
about how to use the robot as he had
used them while in the bunker before his
battery dies Mavis agrees to power
Joel's radio long enough to briefly
contact Amy where he learns that new
survivors have reached her Colony
promising to lead them away to safety as
Mavis still has some power hour left he
sits outside with Joel listening to his
parents story he then shows some
pictures of his parents and Joel gets
emotional seeing this with this sweet
moment Mavis battery dies and Joel sets
onto his journey to meet Amy the next
day Joel and boy are attacked by a queen
sand gobbler plaid had warned him about
it being the most dangerous of the all
monsters while running away Joel falls
down but manages to take boy and hides
behind a tree trunk Joel also shuts boy
mouth as the creature is very sensitive
to sound thinking that there is no one
around the sand gobbler starts to return
back just then boy barks as he sees the
blanket of his previous owner flying
away giving away their position the
creature again chases them but Joel
manages to kill the queen with the
grenade and jumps into the river he then
yells at boy for putting their life in
danger after swimming across a river
Joel is covered in poisonous leeches and
starts to hallucinate from their venom
he swallows some leaves as an antidote
as suggested by Clyde out of nowhere Amy
appears there and Joel wakes to finally
see her Joel is extremely Delight to
meet Amy but is again unconscious
because of the poison from leeches he
regains his Consciousness inside Amy's
colony where she leads a beach colony of
elderly survivors who all depend on her
Joel is introduced to the new survivors
led by cap a former Royal Australian
Navy sailor who has managed to procure
an old yacht as everyone celebrates
their imminent departure Amy confesses
she is glad to see Joel but has no
romantic interest in him as she is still
mourning the death of someone close to
her hearing this from Amy a devastated
Joel realizes that Amy cannot love him
the way she used to before and decides
to return to his Colony Joel contacts
his previous Colony members on the radio
learning that it has become unsafe to
stay there and that they too must leave
soon he takes out the map that his team
handed him and finds some sweet and
heartfelt messages written all over it
Joel then realizes that it is the team
where he truly belongs and decides to
head back to his Colony later Joel
notices something odd and the berries
serve to him by cap he browses through
the drawings in his notebook and
confirms the berries to be poisonous he
then runs out to warn Amy realizing cap
is not to be trusted but gets knocked
out by a punch when he gains his
Consciousness he finds himself Amy and
the rest of her Colony tied up on the
beach cap reveals that he and his crew
are actually Pirates Who raid colonies
for food and fuel he says that his yacht
is towed to the place with the help of a
giant crab he summons a crab monster
rigged with a makeshift electric collar
to eat the colonists meanwhile Joel and
Amy escaped their Bonds in charge at the
Pirates boy returns and saves Amy who
steals a hand cannon from one of the
Pirates Joel is about to kill the crab
but he determines that the monster is
not hostile by looking into its eyes and
instead uses the cannon to destroy the
electric collar which was controlling it
the crab leaves Joel unharmed and sinks
the yacht devouring cap and the pirates
in the next scene Joel recommends Amy
and her colony to head north they share
a romantic goodbye kiss and Amy promises
she will find him Joel gives her a book
containing all of his survival knowledge
and tracks all the way back back to his
Colony when Joel reaches home his Colony
members are extremely happy to see him
back alive Joel then persuades his
members to head towards the mountains as
they are tired of hiding undergrounds on
the radio Joel sends a message to other
colonies sharing his experiences so they
will also be ready to leave and meet
back at the surface as everyone heads
North Clyde and minnow already in the
mountains wonder if Joel Will Survive
the next Journey thanks for watching
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn on the
notifications so you won't miss any of
our new videos